hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on recent
developments in ion mobility mass
spectrometry enabling structural and
isomeric separation for large and small
molecules by dr john fieldstead the
distinguished scientist and senior
director for ion mobility and
intellectual property at agilent and i'm
susie valdez of lab roots and i'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin i want to encourage you to
engage with us you can submit as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation simply type
them into the ask a question box on the
left
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that support
tab at the top right or use that ask a
question box on the left join me now and
please welcoming dr fee yeld said you
may now begin your presentation welcome
sir
my name is john fieldstead i'm with
agilent technologies in santa clara
california
it's a pleasure today to join you as
part of the solving the unsolved mass
specs series i have about two principal
topics that i'd like to cover today the
first is to do with resolving power
increased enhancements in iron mobility
mass spectrometry that's largely
associated with small molecule analysis
and the other happens to do with
collision induced unfolding of proteins
large molecule analysis application
when we look at the history of ion
mobility we realize it goes back uh over
100 years but it's really only been the
last 15 years that ion mobility has been
effectively coupled to mass spectrometry
for analytical analysis
today i'd like to focus on these numbers
one two three and four which are various
mechanisms for which eye mobility
resolving power can be enhanced
let's begin with uh trapped ion mobility
mass spectrometry this is offered by
broker it was introduced in
2016. the analyzer is composed of two
sections one a section that accumulates
and a second section that does the
actual iron mobility separation and this
can be
achieved at various
rates
release rates of the ions through that
analyzer section and the exit funnel
the resolving power is increased as that
scan speed is decreased by the 1 4 power
and let's look at an example of how that
actually works out
you can see on the left hand side these
two hydroxy flavonones that are
separated nicely at a resolving power of
40. now this analysis was done a full
spectral range so nearly 200 square
angstroms and acquired at frame 8 11
frames per second
on the right hand side is the exact same
sample
and in this case the to increase the
resolving power to about 120 uh the scan
rate of releasing ions through that
separation had to be dramatically
reduced and so to do that accomplish
that this the range was reduced to 16
square angstroms that's the width of
what you actually see in the spectrum
and the acquisition rate was reduced to
two and a half per second so this
results in a total reduction of about 50
fold
in in scan speed and the square root of
50 gives you about a factor of three so
that's consistent with the results that
you see there
when we consider what that means for the
actual analytical application we start
at a resolving power of base resolving
power of about 40 and that gives us
essentially a full range analysis over
mass and collision cross section
when we want to increase the resolving
power in this case to 120 then that
reduction in the actual range that could
be monitored to accommodate that slower
speed as well as the acquisition rate is
reduced by about a factor of four as
well then this is uh turns the analysis
essentially into a target analysis um to
be able to accomplish that that higher
performance okay it also comes with a
reduction in in sensitivity and in
in a dynamic range
as a result of the reduced frame rates
uh with waters and their traveling wave
eye mobility system uh uh the in in the
introduction of a cyclic device which
you can see in the center of the screen
here which allows incoming ions to then
be uh uh pushed into a ring and that
ring can accommodate multiple cycles
allows each cycle
giving an effective length increase and
increase in resolving power
when we look at how that deploys then
analytically here's a couple of analytes
that they've published on where we have
a single pass achieving a resolving
power of nearly 80.
and then once 16 passes are accomplished
you can see their resolving power over
300 so it's really quite impressive um
albeit though each time we increase the
number of passes the actual ccs window
that can be uh put into play also
commensurately decreases so once again
turning the analysis into a target
analysis
with with that increase in resolving
power
so if we look at that once again
a first pass a second pass
each time reducing the actual zoom
window and then also increasing the
analysis time
i'd like to now move to resolving power
uh increases that are possible with
agilent time of flight mass spectrometry
um the instrument on the left is the
drift two bind mobility system that was
introduced in
2014-15 and the one on the right is a
new system that we're working together
with with
mobileiron you can see the logo on the
front which is a developing technology
that came from pacific northwest
national labs dick smith's lab there and
increase and makes advantage of an
increased path length through
through the select through the the uh
the slim technology
okay
let's uh under the hood we see the drift
tube on the left that's the standard
6560 instrument and on the right you can
see the serpentine path of the
of the structures for lossless eye
manipulation or the acronym we use is
slim
all right and needless to say with the
increased path length we're going to
expect a longer resolving higher
resolving power
the uh the instrument looks like this it
actually has a traveling wave that's
implemented on circuit boards these are
planar circuit boards you see that here
on the right and what we've done is
we've zoomed in on portion of that the
circuit boards actually exist in a layer
there's two and upper and lower and the
fields that are generated between them
are allowed for the propagation of the
traveling wave and also the confinement
lines or the red lines that have rf that
hold the ions in play there
now with that you can imagine we're
going to take that 13 meters and now
we're going to sample it with the q top
mass spectrometer
this is nice because it's a modular
design that allows for the slim
separation front end to be coupled to
and agilent cubed off an existing system
now we'll look at this the
time-of-flight analyzer is the back end
of the q-top and as you well know the
acquisition rate of time of flights are
very fast in the 1700 mass range mode
that's 8 000 transients per second so
let's let those ions fly through the
slim device and as you see the
acquisition of top transients captures
each of those analytes passing through
that have been separated by ion mobility
and when we
transfer that to collision cross-section
calibration then we get a resolving
power of about 250 to 300 okay
now let's actually look at this here we
realize
there's a time advantage
versus condensed phase separation so
let's take a look at this in more detail
that 13 meter slim separation is
accomplished in about a second and a
half
and uh and achieves a resolving power of
about 250. so you see the the the square
plotted in the middle of the frame there
we can also redirect those ions that are
about to exit and go to the qtof and
re-pass them through the slim device for
a second or third time and uh this
increases then the resolving power with
each pass now let's compare that as i
mentioned to to say uplc which achieves
similar resolving powers albeit
at a
a longer time scale so the opportunity
that presents itself is it can we take
some traditional uplc
uh separations and remap those into a
slim separation achieving similar peak
capacity but in a substantially reduced
time scale the reason why we're able to
do this with slim is because if nothing
else and what we'll show you to is just
single pass
separations is that we're able to
collect all the ions it's not just a
targeted resolution enhancement approach
so how do we do an analysis like that
well we can take the analyte of question
and we can introduce it in a liquid
stream to the atmospheric pressure ion
source and we can do it as a flow
injection analysis plug that's what i'm
depicting here or we can do it as an
lcms experiment but i'm going to show a
few uh fia experiments so i wanted to
give a little bit of background on that
first so we're collecting frames these
are the two-dimensional ion mobility by
mass separations and that takes about a
second and a half so we can get 20
frames in 30 seconds for in this example
and we can sum those frames together now
that's going to increase sensitivity and
dynamic range
and now we have a a essentially a
two-dimensional separation one by
mobility and one by mass and if we wish
we can remap that mobility and plot it
as retention time that way we can use
existing uh qtof data analysis packages
and uh and uh and and existing workflows
through for through any informatics that
a person would want to do in that regard
so let's take it some examples of that
the first one i'd like to do is yes it
is a large molecule and we're going to
give a little bit of an example that
intact but we're also going to look at
some digestions as well
so first considering the the some of the
challenges with monoclonal antibodies
and and looking at their stability
then um
deamidation and isomerization those are
two of the toughest ones because the
mass shifts are rather small
let's take a look at the nist standard
that's referred to here on the screen
and on the left hand side the first
example is just doing what we mentioned
there doing an fya analysis uh summing
two minutes worth of
frame transients that are required and
summing those and then remapping them
into a into a standard retention time
mass spectral context and then analyzing
those using a standard deconvolution a
multi-charge date deconvolution and
looking at then the glycosylation sites
by by mass here
on on that intact protein
the all this can also be done with the
subunit and in this case the subunit
instead of doing an fia analysis we
actually did a short alciements analysis
you can see the results here comparing
straight lcms without ion mobility
together with the addition of our
mobility now let's take a look at what
that ion mobility can do and let's look
at it at this fc region for just a
minute
you can see some of the raw data on the
left here in a two-dimensional plot what
we're going to do is now take and pull a
spectrum off of that look at the arrival
time
here in milliseconds and we're going to
look at this at the fc region at two
different time points uh during the
reduction one at 20 minutes and one at
60 minutes and you can notice the black
trace here at 20 minutes the disulfide
bonds are are still intact there
uh have not been broken and
reduced and then we can see the arrival
time distribution is
is shorter
than after 60 minutes of reduction when
the bonds break and of course now you've
got an elongation and opening of that fc
region it gives uh um goes from a
compact format structure to more open
we can also as i mentioned to a digest
here and in this case we've done a short
lcms
separation
just five minutes
and
and during that we've been able using
peptide mass fingerprinting we get a
nearly a 99 coverage
when we move over and want to see the
value of the ion mobility let's look at
the right hand side here
so if we look at this here we've got
asparagine the n here and the native
form
but
we also notice that some of that is is
converting here to aspartic and
isosparic acid we can actually see both
forms both conversions here because each
of those are actually drift time
resolved as you can see in these stacked
plots
we go to this second peptide here okay
in this case two asparagines and we're
seeing actually just a single conversion
at this point
that we can see that separation and
drift time this is a big help because
otherwise just that single shift in one
mass value or
two of them shifting each by one would
largely overlap the isomeric the the
isotopic patterns that we have from the
native form and generally that's
achieved the better separation by
chromographic separation allows for that
distinction and here we're able to
achieve that in just a five minute time
scale because um we're not relying on
the chromatographic separation rather
we're augmenting that with the mobility
separation
let's look at now some release glycans
okay
this is from our rna speed and from
fedorin and we can see here that this
analysis for these release glycans is uh
generally done over 180 minutes and you
can see some extracted iron
chromatograms from the ver from various
glycan families here over that
separation
we've done a flow injection analysis
over two minutes and now we're letting
the drift time and or the arrival time
distribution of the slim actually be
mapped here to the to the x-axis as as
this is the case in a chromatographic
separation and looking at the various
glycan families that separate here very
nicely the thing that is the interesting
contrast is if we compare the two-minute
infusion
to the
180-minute separation this is a 90-fold
increase in throughput and on the right
hand side you can see some of the the
comparisons of the separations that were
done chromatographically or by drift to
show that we're getting similar results
and we're able to quantitate on these in
a very similar fashion and if we look at
these relative responses here across
these families in the bars we can see
that that matches very nicely to the
spectral display that we have here from
the slim
uh it can also be applied to
complex systems like lipids so here
with the various isomeric forms of
lipids we've got cis trans separations
that are now possible
we have sn positional isomers that are
separated as you can see
in the middle
as well as moving the double bond uh
along the chains we can separate those
double bond positions very exciting
so to summarize here's where we stand
with the slim technology now let's add
on the drift tube technology and we see
that with a shorter drift length
compared to the 13 meter path we also
get a lower resolving power typical
resolving power between
50 and 55 for singly charged analyte but
we also notice that it happens in a
rather short time scale this is down at
around 50 milliseconds
okay
so with that that measurement system is
very similar to what we just saw with
the slim we have a drip separation now
this is happening as i mentioned at 50
milliseconds that's 20 times a second
and the top
spectra are being acquired in the same
way
and we get a resolving power between 50
and 60. well you may ask yourself
where's the high resolution in that well
that comes by some new methodologies
that we've just been applying here in
the last year let's take a look at how
we achieve that
first we realize that eye mobility and
in particular drift to iron mobility can
be operated in a novel two different two
principle ways one is a trap and release
as you see here a single pulse for the
standard separation time of say 50 or 60
milliseconds but we can also do a
multiplex mode
where we have multiple
traps and releases all in a single
analysis period all within a single
frame
all right and that gives a great
increase in sensitivity duty cycle and
we can also use that to benefit
resolving power let's see how we do that
first let's make that measurement again
this is just uh
now looking at that multiplexing where
we realize with that pseudorandom
sequence we continue to divide drive
multiple accumulations and releases in
each measurement cycle and once again
we're acquiring that at about eight
thousand top transients per second to be
able to capture that to enable to use
this data we have to go through a
a demultiplexing step
and we take that pseudorandom sequence
that coding we know exactly when the
ions were released
and now we can apply that we take the
open gates and the closed gates so we
transform those to ones and minus ones
and we overlay that on the raw data
using an autocorrelation to be able to
then grab each of those multiple pulses
across the frame summing them up based
on that correlation and that gives a
sensitivity increase
now we can take it a step further if we
want to do resolution enhancement by
actually knowing what each ion
uh characteristics are in terms of
passing through the drift tube now we
trap them and we release them and during
that we get a a diffusion broadening
that results in a resolving power of
about 50 as i mentioned before if we
take that
that
what we refer to as an instrument
function which is really just the actual
envelope of the of the peak width of the
eye mobility separation in a fundamental
sense and we replace the ones and and
minus ones or the uh with that
instrument function we can now
use that to do a simultaneous
deconvolution as we're doing the on
autocorrelation function
and that results then through that
deconvolution and as you see here
depicted as a smaller point which is
trying to give the in giving the
indication of a higher resolving power
so
we realized that those points were
starting to get so narrow that the basic
top acquisition rate of 8000 left the
mobility separation peaks under
sample
so in a post-processing sense now before
we do the deconvolution we actually
interpolate additional top
spectra
to up to 24 000 now per second
all right and with that fundamental
higher sampling rate
we're able to produce a higher
resolution when we pass the infrared
function over and apply the
deconvolution algorithm
okay let's see what that looks like with
some real data here you can see on the
left hand side uh some pe lipids
and um you can see the isotopic envelope
and you can see that there are multiple
pulses all stacked over the in this case
60 millisecond per frame uh separation
time now using that autocorrelation
routine and the deconvolution you can
see that function when that passes over
we're able to get that resolution
enhancement and now we're showing the
output data file on the right-hand side
of this fly slide notice the increased
resolving power also notice that those
peaks are taller the actual area or ion
current has not been lost and so we
actually get higher detectability from
that as well
now this is accomplished in two programs
i mentioned the first program he has
does achieves a drift interpolation this
is done through the pnl preprocessor uh
this is a work that we continue to do
with the pacific northwest national labs
and development of these
pre-processing routines and the second
is the autocorrelation and
demultiplexing and deconvolution that
happens through
the uh
through the high-resolution demux tool
which you see on the right hand side
here and this is provided by richard
konokumusa rk
research
now it's interesting to consider that
the computer is actually becoming part
of the analyzer in a way that's similar
to how fourier transform works where the
fourier transform analysis gives the
high resolving power in this case the
the high resolution demultiplexing gives
us the high reliability resolving power
let's look at a few examples here
here's a couple three uh milk
oligosaccharides
uh
and
we're looking here at uh at these in the
standard demultiplexing mode
and you can see the peak on the left
hand side here has a wide is a wide peak
and it's not hard to imagine that there
are multiple isomers present underneath
underneath that peak unresolved when we
pass it through the preprocessor and the
high resolution demultiplexing then each
of those are nicely revealed um uh each
of those three isomers let's actually
look at that comparison now between the
standards individual standards that you
can see in these taller three plots and
then when combined together into a
single sample and run together which is
what you saw before you see the three
lower plots uh here with their label
with their labeled isomers
uh the resolving power on this is where
chibi is about 250. so we modeled a
resolving power of 250 you could easily
do that mathematically and when we go to
map that on top we see very nice
agreement so we're really quite pleased
let's look at an example of high
resolution multiplexing by examining
some work that's been done in aaron
baker's lab at nc state
one of our students karen butler has
been looking at some
asparagine
uh ice peptides in the lab there that
then deamidate and uh isomerized to both
aspartic acid and isosportic acid
she's assembled seven different peptides
examine these in both positive and
negative mode
and as you can see from this plot here
the these peptide pairs uh differ in
collision cross section ranging anywhere
from typically about one to three
percent in collision cross-section
the vertical lines that you see there at
about two and a quarter percent
uh represent the limit that they're able
to separate directly from at a resolving
power of 50 typical with uh drift tube
and mobility
now when we apply multiplexing and high
resolution demultiplexing then we're
able to achieve a resolving power that
allows us to separate down to one
percent and in some cases even lower
so let's take a look at one of these
pairs this is a number two here and that
had a separation of about uh just under
one and a half percent
uh we can see here in a standard drift
tube operation that they're clearly more
than
they're clearly an isomeric pair here
by the profile of the peak and yet it's
still unresolved when we apply a
multiplexed acquisition and then and
then demultiplexed at high resolution
then we can very nicely separate both
the aspartic acid and isospartic acid
isomers of these peptides
one of the things that's very powerful
about this technique is that it can be
applied
for very complex mixtures and in this
case this is a hela cell digest and
we've been able to treat thousands of
peptides that have been separated here
with resolution enhancement so um
instead of having it to be a targeted uh
on one or two analytes during an lcms
separation or switched throughout a
separation we can in retrospect uh be
able to treat large numbers here's just
a quick example just jumping into that
data set you can see the standard
capabilities on the left and now the
high resolution demultiplexing results
on the right hand side
now what's nice with this workflow is it
can also be married together with a
standard data dependent acquisition
workflow in this case
this sample was first analyzed by by in
standard qtof mode using data dependent
acquisition msms taking those uh
msms spectra that are generated doing a
database search and identification
loading that library into skyline and
producing then that skyline library
which you can see listed on the left
hand side now what i've done is i've
taken and
re-analyzed that you saw that in the
previous slide using ion mobility
separation and processing that data with
uh with the preprocessor and the high
resolution demultiplexing and now you
see the same analyte analyzed now in ion
mobility we have such high selectivity
that we can now use just the selectivity
eye mobility the mass accuracy and of
course the retention time to give us the
uniqueness we we want and because
there's no switching back and forth
between ms and ms ms then we're able to
capture the full iron current of the
precursors at high resolution high
selectivity and do our quantitation in a
way that gives us higher sensitivity
than we have been able to achieve
previously
now the good thing about this technique
the high resolution demultiplexing is it
still has all of the benefits of the um
drift tube system in that it has very
accurate ccs measurement very
reproducible
and uh and it is standardized off of of
off of the interlab study which allows
us to get consistent ccs values from
instrument to instrument in the lab to
lab and these same techniques and uh and
workflows have been used at the mclean
lab to generate the collision
cross-sectional compendium which has
brought data together for many labs
to be able to have a large compendium
with extremely good agreement i believe
it's at 0.6 is the end is the is the is
a typical search base that we can use
for for for agreements that's percent
now to refresh that once again we're
saying let's focus on high resolution
resolution and eye mobility we have
three approaches that we can see is the
summary slide um the first we talked
about is the travel as the trapped ion
mobility and as we increase resolving
power then the percentage of the ion
mobility frame that we can use just
based on speed limitations decreases the
same is true with the cyclic as we send
it around the loop in multiple times
with the slim technology we already
start with a very high utilization the
full frame data
and um and uh and that would achieve a
resolving power of about 250
and then in the case of the drift tube
eye mobility we start at about 50 but we
can increase that resolving power with
high resolution demultiplexing while
maintaining full
uh full-frame data acquisition
now let's turn the second half of the
talk to looking at
some work that we've been doing with
large molecules
when we look at the collision-induced
activation here is the back end of the
what we refer to as the desolvation
assembly and you can see this is the
capillary that is the exit end of the
capillary coming into the mass
spectrometer high vacuum the front end
of that which you don't see is what's
present in the atmospheric pressure ion
source
you can see it schematically shown below
here's that ion transfer capillary and
what we've done is we've added a small
cap on the back end you can see here
that allows us to create a high field
potential gradient here between the
capillary exit and that cap so that we
can accelerate ions and activate them
against the gas that is the nitrogen gas
that's emerging from that exit capillary
the ions are then recaptured here the
high pressure funnel and then they're
redirected and trapped in the trapping
funnel we have parallel accumulation as
you saw earlier
so that ions are trapped here while the
previous analysis or trap cycle is being
performed
in the drift tube
we can step that potential over the
course of the analysis uh in this case
i'm showing it a little bit of an
extended time but it can be also shorter
and as we increase that potential then
we're increasing the activation energy
that we're going to apply to to protein
systems
we've been working together with the
university of michigan and the great
researchers there
with brandon alexey and kiki and their
teams
great graduate students and post docs
and we'll look at some of the work
that's resulted there's a lot that's
been published in this we know the
principles we just mentioned this each
time increasing the collision voltage in
the source ahead of the mobility
separation and as we activate these
proteins they unfold and then their
various regions start to become exposed
okay
now we can plot this and here you can
see this is showing the trapping voltage
or the collision voltage that we're
applying in the early days it was just
the trapping voltage that we used and we
can actually compare one result to the
other and these are some different plots
that are shown
of course there's been a lot of work
that's already been published on this
and i won't refresh all of that here for
us today
when we look at this here's some igg
examples where we've looked across igg
one two three and four
those have been published previously in
this case we're going to turn our
attention to a comparison between igg-1
and looking at some biotherapeutics in
this case used for for crohn's disease
remicade is the init is the innovator
there and we're going to compare this to
the two bile similars that you see
plotted and you can see how interesting
that will be do they really have the
same structural confirmation as we
activate them are there subtle
differences that start to emerge in
those intact structures
so let's look at that in more detail
okay once again here we have the
innovator and the two biosimilars and
what we're going to do is we're going to
now
zoom in using this ciu suite software
to be able to look at these inflection
points
between these static states
so here's one activation energy uh a cu
and we call it a 50 because it's the 50
50 percent point between between these
plateaus
now we also in the drift tube systems
can monitor multiple charge states
simultaneously so we're looking at the
25 to 29 charge dates and we're looking
then at the ci you the 50 points for
these various charge states and we're
looking at that at both the first
inflection here plotted above and the
section flexion here for the second
transition uh plotted in the in the blow
and you can see in this case for example
in the 27 charge state look at the
differences between these various
between the the initiator the innovator
and the biosimilars okay
particularly between the rem flexes you
can see that right there so by actually
being able to profile across
uh charge states and combining all of
this
information together we can have a very
good p-value
for being able to distinguish between
event innovators and biosimilars
now let's add some additional
information to this to the story let's
look at adding collision uh
uh
electron capture dissociation to the
collision-induced unfolding this work
you're going to hear about more today
from from joe beckman so this is just a
one slider
where we've been able to insert a an ecd
cell on front of the collision cell the
collision cell has been shortened just
slightly to accommodate that ecd
cell okay
now with that we're going to look at
producing ecd
fragments
okay under two different activation
states in the protein one here with low
collision activation and one here where
the protein is more unfolded okay
and as we do that we can get ecd spectra
we can get those ecd spectra at low
energies at higher energies we can also
do cid experiments still and here we're
showing how we can combine these
together so here's 100 volt activation
here's 400 volt activation you can see
in the red and combined we're getting a
lot more more information than we were
now let's look at a human serum albumin
same same story here we've got that
activation
okay here's here's the hsa here we are
largely intact here's now performing ecd
and as i mentioned we can also do cid
studies as well so let's look at this
again here's at 150 volts of activation
in the source not much unfolding at that
point okay that's still the compact form
now at 250 we get a very different ecd
spectrum notice all the information that
we're able to achieve there okay
and what that allows us to do is start
to make an association
of the various domains where those
fragment ions are starting to be uh
produced either by ecd or by the by uh
by collision induced association in
those sub-units of the protein
there are other activities now for the
very end of our talk i mentioned that
we'll spend just a second on on imaging
you're going to have more of that today
um from vladimir who's the last talk of
the day um but the first uh one to
highlight is some work that we're doing
by coupling ir maldessi
to our 6560 this is iron mobility as a
as you can imagine in the short drift
times that we have
we're able to
get
couple this very nicely to laser pulse
rates and the circuitry that you see on
the right shows how those have been
enacted together
we're also able to work with ap molding
imaging and as i mentioned that's what
you'll hear more about today okay so
lastly i would like to thank you for
your attention and would invite any
questions that you might have
thank you so much dr fieldstedt for that
informative presentation
we've already received some great
questions so we're going to begin the q
a portion of our presentation and i want
to encourage our audience to go ahead
and ask some questions you can go right
to that left side to the ask a question
box and click send
so let's take a look at the questions
that are already coming in
our first question is when will the slim
technology be commercially available
yes it's a great question um we're
currently working together as i
mentioned with mobile ion
they have
several beta systems that are already in
deployment in key labs uh across the u.s
and
they uh
great results are coming back from those
uh the actual launch of the product is
due for uh um the asms time frame this
coming year in 2021 so we're quite
excited about that
thank you so much
and is there a requirement of specific
signal strength required for doing the
multiplexing and this is a two-part
question john the problem we are facing
the audience member says the problem we
are facing during the multiplexing is
that it is not effective for low
intensity signals the traditional step
field technique is more effective at
times where the signal intensity is very
low so they're wondering is there a
requirement for that specific signal
strength
uh actually uh no the signal strength
could go very very low um there are some
cases where somebody loses the sequence
in the pseudorandom sequence and then it
doesn't decode properly so that's uh
that's a defect that i have seen and i
believe that the question and the source
where it's coming from i've looked at
that data and that answers that question
quite well um so uh no the signal levels
can be very low and it does help in
insensitivity in that regard uh for the
high resolution demultiplex and because
that involves a deconvolution step then
yes ion statistics does play a role in
that
thank you so much
and do you see a sensitivity enhancement
for the ion mobility enable applications
yes absolutely um you know if you look
at the fundamental duty cycle then it
can be as high as 50 with multiplexing
so that's why i say it really is a
sensitivity enhancement there and uh and
yet we get an eightfold factor
measurement cycle
the um
the uh the the opportunity the
immobility presents is because you have
a different a second degree of
separation uh before iron mass
measurement then uh then interferences
can often be removed from that analysis
and so that gives you a substantial
increase in signal to noise and this is
particularly predominant can be seen
very nicely for example in proteomic
applications as well
thank you so much
dr field said how effective is the slim
technology for separating stereo isomers
in essential oils what is the drift gas
used for in the character
molecules
yeah trying to do chiral separations
that is really a push that's a challenge
that's getting down uh require resolving
power that's that's higher than what
we're able to do in drift time ion
mobility in most cases i think this
would be a great opportunity to start
posing those types of problems for the
slim technology uh slim technology has
incredible resolving power capabilities
and will be exciting work to see in the
future
dr field said thank you again for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience and i do want to remind them
before you say anything as a reminder to
all of them questions we didn't have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed via the email you provided at
the time of registration go ahead and
provide some closing remarks before we
go today
yeah there's there's one question i see
coming here at the end you know uh great
dynamic range enhancements that we're
seeing from these technologies
so uh factors of between oh four and ten
um i'd like to i just say that it's an
exciting time for uh trying to solve the
unsolved with iron mobility being able
to to pull out ice american comformeric
information about small and large
molecules is a new opportunity it's like
when we went from low resolution mass
spectrometry with quadruples to high
resolution mass applications as well the
world started to unfold for us and i
think we're going to see that over the
coming years thank you very much
and thank you again dr fiat said and
thanks for everyone who participated we
encourage you to check out the exhibit
hall and the rest of the agilent event
take care stay safe and stay healthy
bye-bye now
[Music]